- Nahre how's it going?
- Hey LA.
- I got a question for you,
what is your
definition of music?
Languages evolve over time.
If I wrote this message
and mailed it to the 1960s,
it will be dismissed
as nonsense.
Like any language, what
is considered music
is also constantly changing.
When The Ramones released
their debut album in 1976,
parents hated it and radio
stations wouldn't play it.
But three decades later, their
music was selling Diet Pepsi.
There have always been
musicians and composers
that push the edges
of what we call music.
- In the early 20th
century some composers
began to reject conventional
ideas of harmony and tonality.
And no composer did this more
boldly than Arnold Schoenberg
who wrote music that
was so against the times
that audiences would often
boo, laugh and heckle
at his performances.
Imagine it's the 1920s,
your ears are probably more
accustomed to the sounds
of composers such as Mozart.
Then you hear performance
of Schoenberg's,
suit for piano Opus 25.
To most audiences it
sounded like random chaos
but what was Schoenberg doing?
Opus 25 was actually the
first piece composed entirely
using the 12-tone technique,
which is a compositional
approach that
Schoenberg invented.
Using this technique,
you order the 12 tones
of the chromatic scale
in a particular order
called a tone row.
So here's an example
of a tone row.
The idea is to make
sure that all 12 tones
are equally emphasized.
This creates a sort of democracy
for tones don't relate
to a center like this.
The C clearly has more
weight over the other notes.
A tone row doesn't have this.
I ended on C but
the whole phrase
doesn't feel like
it's in C major.
Schoenberg's rigid
ideas of a tonality
never caught on with
a widespread audience.
But artists from other
musical backgrounds
would go on to explore
similar methods
later in the 20th century.
Most notably in jazz.
- In 1961, the Bill
Evans Trio recorded
and now legendary
live jazz album called
Sunday at the Village Vanguard.
Do you hear those
traditional ideas
of harmony and
chord progressions?
Now check out this
excerpt from Free Jazz,
an album released that same year
by saxophonist Ornette Coleman.
This is one of the first
albums to usher in free jazz.
A movement that like Schoenberg
challenged traditional
ideas of tonality.
The goal of artists like Coleman
wasn't necessarily to get
each tone equal emphasis
but rather to drop all the rules
so they can express themselves
as freely as possible.
You can hear it in the works
of artists like Cecil Taylor,
Albert Ayler and
even John Coltrane.
Soon after free jazz
took off in the 1960s
three sisters from New Hampshire
also began making music that
challenged traditional ideas
of tonality and harmony
with a three piece band
called The Shaggs but unlike
Coltrane or Schoenberg
who were pushing music from
within established music scenes,
The Shaggs we're definitely
pushing from the outside.
- If someone thinks
The Shaggs are a bunch
of no talent hillbillies,
I understand that.
Shaggs music doesn't reach out.
The way that conventional
pop reaches out
and tries to, you know,
grab you with a hook.
The Shaggs kind of exist
in a little bit of a bubble
and you've got to get
inside that bubble.
And that I think applies
to the best outsider music.
It pulls you into
something really unusual
and that's one of the
adventures of outsider music
that I really love.
If you don't like it, ignore it.
Don't listen to me, it's okay.
- One of the most famous
fans of outsider music
was David Bowie who based his
Ziggy Stardust as alter ego
in part on an outsider musician
named Legendary Stardust Cowboy.
While the bulk of outsider
music never ventures
beyond open mics and
the record collections
of a few dedicated
fans, Legendary
Stardust Cowboy's music
has actually been played
in space, aboard Skylab
the American space
station launched in 1973.
Is that the bugle from
Legendary Stardust Cowboy?
Yes
- So what happens when a
composer wants to make a sound
that can't be created by
a traditional instrument?
You make your own.
That's what American
composer Harry Partch did.
Partch was interested
in micro-tonality
and a 12 tone octave
just wasn't enough.
He composed using 43 tones
within the traditional octave
and created instruments
out of everything
from old airplane
parts to liquor bottles
so that he could play
his compositions.
But no composer more boldly
challenged traditional ideas
of music and confused
audiences in the process
than John Cage an American whom
Arnold Schoenberg described
as not a composer but
an inventor of genius.
Cage knew how to
play and compose
for traditional instruments
but he's most famous
for writing compositions that
featured sounds generated
from everyday objects.
He also pioneered the
idea of the prepared piano
A piano that's been
temporarily altered
to produce exotic
and percussive sounds
by placing objects like
screws, wood and rubber
between the strings.
- Cage left many
decisions up to chance
to arrange his imaginary
landscape number four,
which calls for 24
performers to turn 12 radios
to certain volumes and
stations at specific times.
Cage used an ancient
Chinese divination system
called the I-ching to decide
what should come next.
- Although cage was
making music with radios
and definitely
not for the radio,
his work has influenced
many well known musicians.
John Cale of The Velvet
Underground was a student
of Cage and Radiohead's
Thom Yorke called him
one of his all-time art heroes.
Let's find a template that
is completely non musical
and then apply our
musical elements into it.
A sentence from the English
language or like a shape.
- It has to be like a dodecagon.
- OK let's use this
word Sound Field.
The name Sound Field.
- Sound Field.
- Like S sounds like this.
- Oh
- Why don't you take sound
and I will take field
- Field?
- Yeah and I won't share
how I'm interpreting it
until after and you do the
same 'cause we can do it.
- Ok
- You can interpret it
because it looks this way
or it sounds this way, it
feels this way, whatever.
- That's gonna be tight
- Let's do it.
I'm more desensitized to
certain types of harmony
and certain types of
textures the older I get.
Once I'm exposed to
this type of dissonance,
let's talk about dissonance.
I get used to that.
And then the next time I hear
it it's no longer as jarring.
- Yeah it'll make you so curios.
- Yeah kind of like food
you know, when you're a kid.
The older you get,
the more exposed you are to
different types of food I mean.
I remember when I was a kid,
I loved the smell of coffee
because it was sweet.
But as soon as I tasted it I
thought, this isn't drinkable,
this isn't edible.
You acquire a taste for
it and then it changes.
- That's probably how a
lot of fans of outsider
music became fans because
when you first hear it's like,
What?
I don't know anybody falls
in love at the first sound.
Where do you draw the line
between music and not music?
That is on the comments
and please subscribe.